[Musique]
6h 9h stéphane soumier réveille la fal
été commises en marge du comici donc été
avec nous est présenté comme ingénieur
jean marc jancovici franck ça vous va
bien une de mes caractéristiques de vos
caractéristiques pas ce que ça veut dire
qu'on parle de solutions pratiques qui
avec vous et c'est notamment à des
solutions pratiques que vous essayer
d'amener aux entreprises sur la
réduction des émissions de co2 et de
toute façon sur l'efficacité énergétique
on va vite j'ai trouvé une image david
cameron avait le red carpet pour les
entrepreneurs et ceux qui voulaient
s'enrichir emmanuel macron à le green
carpet pour l'ensemble des chercheurs et
des ingénieurs qui voudraient travailler
sur contre le réchauffement climatique
et l'efficacité énergétique est-ce qu'il
prend la mesure du défi que lui a lancé
finalement donald trump
alors je sais pas s'il a pris la mesure
du défi parce que je suis pas dans sa
cervelle par contre ce qui est sûr c'est
que il me semble que trump probablement
malgré lui vient d'offrir sur un plateau
d'argent une occasion en or pardon pour
la juxtaposition de ces deux métaux à
notre président pour faire l'histoire
enfin je pense qu'il ay là il a une
opportunité en alignement des planètes
comme il n'en retrouvera pas à mon avis
pendant son quinquennat parce que si on
prend les éléments dans l'ordre on a un
milieu économique et vous avez dû le
voir qui de manière croissante dit
aujourd'hui s'occuper de la question du
climat et de la question de la
dépendance à l'énergie fossile c'est un
vrai sujet faut s'en occuper on a un
président américain qui dit bah moi
m'occuper de ça ça m'intéresse pas donc
ce leadership là ne m'intéresse pas donc
je le laisse à quelqu'un d'autre la
nature ayant horreur du vide il faut
donc que quelqu'un d'autre s'en occupe
alors maintenant quand on regarde la
cartographie des pays et des leaders en
europe
les anglais sont hors jeu parce qu'ils
ont dit l'europe sans doute pour le
moment ils ont leurs propres problèmes
merkel est en fin de mandat macron
jeunes et avec leur énergie qu démarre
son mandat les espagnols et les italiens
sont pas trop dans le débat sur la
construction européenne de manière un
peu centrale
les russes sont pas trop et cetera les
japonais pour qu'il en reste le premier
producteur de pétrole offshore de
pétrole massif les russes nous aurons
donc il en reste un ils roulaient c'est
lui c'est lui avait justement le grain
dairpet c'est assez alors j'ai pas assez
c'est pas eux est par ailleurs tout le
monde va devoir un jour décarbonés son
économie soit parce qu'on le veut soi et
c'est grand paradoxe parce qu'on ne veut
pas alors pourquoi parce qu'on ne veut
pas parce que si on le veut pas le
pétrole le gaz et le charbon iliad a pas
des quantités illimitées sur terre donc
un jour on devra bien en consommer de
moins en moins donc si nous on dit
décarbonés l'économie ça va être notre
grand combe a inventé cette économie
post carbone ça va être notre grand
combat à ce moment on prend une longueur
d'avancé sur quelque chose qui va être
nécessaire un jour ou l'autre à tout le
monde de toute façon est par ailleurs
macron il a une chance d'incarner ce
président jupitérien qu'il veut être
puisque il dit moi mon combat ça va être
les valeurs la société est un acteur
économique vont s'occuper d'économie
mon gouvernement va s'occuper d'eux des
affaires courantes de l'intendance
d'état général de gaulle devant ministre
ça vient des mini-miss s'occupe des
petites choses et moi je vais m'occuper
de donner une grande vision et relever
un défi qui s'apparente à une conquête
de la lune peut très bien être
l'incarnation de ces dix ans donc je ne
sais pas c'est ça à faire non mais si on
fait la similitude avec kennedy c'est
son programme apollo
exactement et et jeu et alors je sais
pas s'il va le faire en tout cas il a
une il a en ce moment une autre affaire
à saisir comme disait l'autre
il a une opportunité absolument
extraordinaire pour pour s'engouffrer
dans cette voie et business france il
paraît qu'ils sont submergés de demandes
depuis que c'est vrai depuis l'ouverture
de ce j'ai eu un échange rapide avec une
personne qui travaille à part avancé
c'est l'everest vadim en rigolant alors
etc non mais attendez rebondir bien qu'à
une appétence c'est à dire qu'elle est
les forces vives
juste en dessous il ya plein de gens qui
ont envie qu'on ait quelque chose qui
ait de la gueule qui s'apparente à
relever un défi et qui nous entraîne
dans cette direction et comme je fait
par ailleurs partie les tristes sires
qui pensent que faire le pari du entre
guillemets redressement économique
c'est-à-dire qu'on retrouve 2% de
croissance par an moi si j'étais lui je
jouerai pas ce jeu là parce que il ya
plein de raisons qui me font penser
qu'il n'y arrivera pas c'est vraiment
sur le terrain du défi à relever des
valeurs et de l'horizon de long terme
qu'on a un combat à gagner oui mais
est-ce que derrière vous ne vendait
encore l'éternel plan d'investissement
public
il va falloir publics ou privés peu
importe maintenant falloir importe comme
ici avec les anglais publics et privés
pas peu importe alors dans le domaine de
l'énergie vous pouvez rien faire sans
que le public sent même pas ce que vous
allez pas investir vous vous investir y
est votre exode investissement vous
investir y et vos économies sur 40 ans
avec un prix de marché qui change toutes
les semaines
non vous ne feriez pas mais cette phrase
lave et vous le savez vous la connaissez
par coeur elle a été prononcée par le
directeur financier d'edf
parlant de le p r qui investirait
l'ensemble de ses économies sur une
technologie qu'on essaye de construire
depuis dix ans et qui n'a pas en moi je
dis on les questionne moi je dis quelque
chose alors si en l'occurrence elle
fonctionne mais par contre ce qui est
vrai c'est qu'il ya une insécurité
majeur c'était que le prix de hinkley
point cela est essentiellement être le
coût du capital
c'est à dire qu'avec un coût du capital
à 10 % ce qui est à peu près ce qu'il va
se passer avec l'épaule vous sortez un
mégawatt heure à 100 euros
vous auriez un coût du capital à deux
vous seriez à 45 donc ce qu'on va payer
haïk l'épaule laisse ce calcul il est un
peu tôt pour moi mais je vous fait quel
effet y est c'est l'insécurité technique
parce que ça fait longtemps que les
anglais ont pas fait un réacteur et
politique parce que personne ne sait si
dans dix ans on va pas changer d'avis
tout à fait c'est ça que vous payez
c'est ça l'ensemble des primes de
risques qui entourent aujourd'hui c'est
la construction d'un tel équipement
donc concrètement l'aï dit il y déploie
son gré une carpette
elle m'a croquer les chercheurs me sont
en train d'arriver mais c'est quoi le
longère deux fondateurs sauf que la
montrerai qui comprend et qui prend la
mesure de ce que il pourrait lancer
c'est de dire que son programme apollo
c'est la décarbonation de l'économie
parce que pour le moment on bricole pour
le moment en france où on a une loi de
transition dont tout le monde retient
l'objectif de baisse du nucléaire sauf
que c'est hors sujet puis juste hors
sujet le nucléaire fait pas de co2 donc
on dit je vais remplacer un truc qui
fait pas de co2 par d'autres trucs qui
font pas de co2 c'est totalement hors
sujet dans notre affaire de dire les les
vrai sujet c'est de faire avec de moins
en moins de pétrole
et ça c'est le problème de la mobilité
un peu du chauffage un peu de
l'industrie et de faire avec de moins en
moins de gaz parce qu'il faut rappeler
que le gaz tout naturel qu'il soit est
une énergie fossile donc il ya des
quantités limitées et ça fait du co2 -
mais quand même et ça c'est le problème
en europe de la génération électrique de
l'industrie et du chauffage
donc les ici sont là nos sujets si on
veut s'occuper sérieusement de la
décarbonation de l'économie et c'est
quelque chose qui est terriblement
structure parce que c'est à cause de
l'énergie abondante que vous et moi on
est dans ce studio au lieu de faire
pousser des patates d'accord le monde
100% vénère on a connu il ya 200 ans
c'était 500 millions d'habitants sur la
planète 25 ans d'espérance de vie à la
naissance et tout le monde agriculteurs
et c'est justement à cause de l'énergie
fossile que le monde est devenu comme il
est donc transformé le monde avec de
moins en moins d'énergie fossile
ce n'est pas anecdotique et un truc que
vous faites à côté des affaires
sérieuses c'est au centre de toutes les
affaires sérieuses je crois que tout le
monde est absolument d'accord mais un
élément intéressant vous avez commencé
en disant le business vannes le business
massivement il ya cette fameuse
initiative donc l'autre slogan
d'ailleurs qui conteste mais cahors
planète bleue genk et we are still in
love et par michael bloomberg l'ancien
maire de new york
ces massifs enfin on faisait les comptes
et je faisais le conte la semaine
dernière de l'ensemble des beats
corporate qui ont réuni we are still in
mais vous êtes sur la moitié du pib
mondial
aujourd'hui et même si on regarde la
france le chic project a lancé avant les
élections le manifeste pour décarbonés
l'europe et ça a été ma plus belle
campagne de marketing direct c'est à
dire que en allons solliciter un parent
un certain nombre de chefs d'entreprises
en france il y en a un sur deux qui nous
a dit oui ce qui est ce qui est énorme
et donc ça veut dire que c'est le boulot
parce que michael bloomberg il est bien
pour incarner sa lourde un responsable
politique et du chef d'une nation d'un
carnet ça bien sûr jean marchand que les
biens sur la noblesse de la politique en
france quand on dits politiques c'est
péjoratif c'est quelqu'un qui parle pour
ne rien dire
or il ya quand même une noblesse et
j'espère qu'on va un jour la retrouver
c'est de faire le ce qui permet la vie
en commun donc de faire des règles les
bonnes pas trop parler mauvaise et
d'incarner une communauté de destin et
c'est de ça dont on a besoin et en fait
nos concitoyens ils ont besoin d'espoir
le ce qui vient de se passer au moment
des élections
et quand même le signe ont le temps
l'abstention que les votes extrémistes
c'est quand même le signe d'un malaise
donc on a besoin d'espoir est-ce que la
noblesse de la politique c'est pas aussi
on va en finir là dessus à un moment
quand même de dire la vérité c'est à
dire que oui on est quand même dans
cette sale guerre dans une immense
tartufferie l'ensemble de ceux qui
dénoncent donald trump les gouvernements
easy sont pas dans les objectifs des
accords de paris à fait d'accord si
aujourd'hui on empile les engagements
que les gouvernements ont pris à paris
on augmente les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre pour tenir les deux degrés et
qui sont présentées par ailleurs comme
quelque chose d'important et
effectivement c'est important eh bien il
faudrait que les émissions commencent à
diminuer de 3% par an demain matin
d'accord or pour le moment ce que les
gens ont dit si on s'engage à les
augmenter pas trop juste on n'y est pas
du tout et je le redis en france c'est
pas le nucléaire qui le sujet attendait
parce qu'il l'est le sujet donc on a une
loi transition énergétique qui nous dit
la moitié de la production électrique
dénucléarisé en 2025
c'est une erreur alors je prends les
paris avec qui veut que hors
effondrement économique on n'y sera pas
donc je vois là j'ouvre les paris que
toute personne ayant envie de parier
évidemment qu'on n'y sera pas ça veut
dire que nicolas hulot
aujourd'hui ministre alors peut-être des
petites choses mais en tout cas là de
cet enjeu majeur doit à un moment dire
la vérité et doit dire non 2025 c'est
pas tenable on dit la vérité c'est 2050
nicholas hill et il est dans une
position très inconfortable
parce que il a un public historique avec
lequel il discute qui et les
associations environnementales qui sont
globalement plutôt anti nucléaire
et il a aujourd'hui une responsabilité
politique parce que sont aujourd'hui les
gens au service desquelles il s est pas
ces gens là juste ses 65 millions de
français voir avec l'option qu'a prise
macron 450 millions d'européens
d'accord c'est ça maintenant son public
et la majeure partie des pays européens
sont pas anti nucléaire tous les pays de
l'est ce vol du nucléaire notamment
parce qu'ils veulent pas des gaz russe
les pays scandinaves hall du nucléaire
et s'ils prennent pas celui d'harry
varieront prendre celui de rosatom
les espagnols n'ont jamais dit qu'ils ne
voulaient pas les anglais qui sont pas
sortis pour me vendra donc on a on est
dans une équation plus compliqué donc la
question c'est quelle vérité il va
pouvoir dire à cri c'est exactement ça
soit dit en passant si j'avais été à sa
place j'aurais demandé à ce que le
nucléaire soit pas chez moi parce que
les autres sujets dont il se sent très
consensuel voulu balancer à l'industrie
exactement vous dites la production
électrique à l'industrie je veux pas en
entendre parler parce que la situation
compliquée et n'a pas été créé par mois
donc que ceux qui l'ont créé se
démerdent avec et moi je m'occupe des
choses qui sont consensuelles donc
m'occuper de réformer la mobilité parce
que tout le monde est d'accord sur le
fait qu' il faut faire quelque chose
quoi exactement mais il faut faire
quelque chose
je m'occupe de la partie bâtiment parce
que tout le monde est d'accord sur le
fait qu'il faut s'occuper de rénover
plus rapidement nos bâtiments
je m'occupe de l'agriculture parce que
il faut une transition écologique dans
l'agriculture je m'occupe de l'industrie
parce que m mais le bâton merdeux chez
les voisins jean marc jancovici sur bfm
business